[Music]  [Music]  this is the hardest blow that has been  dealt to drug trafficking in this  century in our country  and this blows only comparable to the  fall of pablo escobar in the 90s  [Music]  began an important satellite  surveillance mission against him with  agencies from the us and uk  where with each movement with trace  analysts with communications more than  50 experts in signal intelligence  permanently covering that area with an  exact coverage that allowed us to  indicate what his movements were to get  him from his hiding place  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  there is the possibility that these  bring down levels of violence especially  on the communities that he had been  affected by this large organization but  there is no  an effective  solution to the international drug  trafficking problem just by beheading  this type of organizations  [Music]